there's just you know I said this on the
patreon the other day I don't really get
that upset with what people say because
I know how cheap words are and most
people that are talking to you are lying
and making things up most people are
trying to make themselves sound more
interesting by lying they'll they'll
make up things it never happened to them
and they'll say it they'll tell you
stories from movies that they think you
didn't see and then try to pretend that
they lived through them this is how
desperate most human beings are for any
level of attention they just don't care
so words to me don't mean anything
literally no matter what you say I
understand that words of course do mean
things but I always I'm very cynical
unless you show me something unless I'm
able to deduce like what you say to me
is is is absolutely
for the most part as you relevant is
anything when people just pop off and
talk I mean I just I have friends that I
like that I know are pathological liars
that will sit at a table with you and
make up something that's just completely
untrue and get called out on it and
really don't have they don't have any
shame this is just you know I assume
when people are talking to me I assume
that most of them are lying I just
assume you're making you're making
something up and then if I eat turns out
to be true I go nice if it turns out to
be an actually true thing I go oh that's
that's nice you know I just you can't
trust people because all they're trying
to do is be funny or interesting and
they'll say anything people literally
just say anything people talk about
things they have no idea what they're
talking about
and they just go they just go there's no
shame they just they just go they just
go right they just let it out let
doesn't matter they don't have to know
about how many times do we sit in a room
and some people start talking to Rogen
about fighting they start telling him
what the deal is
he said what are you saying shut up will
you shut up they don't care they just
talk because they don't know what else
to do
they're very uncomfortable with silence
so they just they just talk yeah I've
members of my family like that they
don't know anything and they say
ridiculous things because people don't
call them out
and they just say things that don't make
any sense you know yes just let it
happen you can't get angry people get
angry the boomers go on Facebook and
light it up it cares it's funny they're
crazy they're almost dead
they just they've never had a platform
like this where they could just just
launch they could just go it used to be
a corner bar now it's Facebook they
could just launch they don't need to
have the facts doesn't matter to them
they want to be heard boomers by the way
it's the first generation that has a
[ __ ] ton of life experience and and and
and and and then no wisdom like they're
like I've been on this planet a long
time it's extend you ruined it shut the
[ __ ] up half for you not all of you but
a lot of you should just pipe down just
go out quietly you destroy it's like you
inherit a house you burn the house down
just leave quietly just exit quietly
don't be loud on the way out it burned
it down you know and that's not everyone
but you know let them let them launch on
Facebook let them pop off anyone still
on Facebook in any meaningful sense
right now ISM is a mental patient and I
mean that if you're on Facebook trying
to make a point you're nuts
it's oh it's a graveyard I see people
that I like kind of respect on fate and
they go into these multi paragraph
things on Facebook and the tray like
well here's what I see
I see it here's ice hat could there be
anything less appropriate than your take
on Facebook there's nothing to say
anymore on that site it's like the
people still there are sick you're
convincing sick people my mother is in a
mental institution they're all more
well-adjusted than my Facebook Timeline
people talk about drama in these little
comedy community no one cares about your
drama in burnt corn Alabama's comedy
scene stop talking about the open mic
that banned you because you used the
word oriental and then you and did nine
other people in that scene are gonna
have a two thousand comment thread about
free speech after the re thing again
people doing these big comment threads
about fries be shut the [ __ ] up you also
have the freedom to not speak does it
affect you you're unaffected by this you
don't need to go into all but this is
what people do when and I've said it
before they're feral they've been bit
social media has given them this idea
that they have to have a take on things
just just let it go does it no one gives
a [ __ ] about what you're saying calm
down
it's crazy stop posting libertarian
memes if you live with your mother
stop talking about a bad socialism as if
you live with your mother get out of
your how these Long Island guys live
with their mom
socialism is bird crop it will shut up
your eating cereal that someone bought
for you you're on the family plan you
and you about you're in your 30s
it's like that's what Facebook is it's
like people have Authority good are you
my favorite ones they go get off my page
take that off my page
this is my page I don't own a house but
I own this page I have this page where I
can enforce the rules go I have it to
sell some tickets to put some merch out
there there was a lot I had a lot of fun
with it back in the day I used to write
these long things troll people there was
a lot of fun but it's over now and if
you 96 you know don't be on tech not
like maybe we'll all have to be on
tick-tock there's just something super
sad about seeing old people on that app
I know that we have to get on it
probably for our careers but there's
something sad about it but you know you
feel odd being onyx Evans 15 it's like
I'm not really trying to entertain 15
year-olds I don't care I don't know you
you shouldn't think I'm funny you you
can't buy tickets to my show you there's
we're not doing anything here there's no
overlapping life experiences of me and
you you were born after 9/11 you know
what I mean I was born before 9/11 and
then I learned that 9/11 wasn't real so
yeah we're never gonna yeah I'm not
doing your new dance on tick-tock okay i
watch the Towers fall and found that
there were Holograms Heike I'm not doing
you dance
I'm not doing you fortnight dance okay
I'm awake
you don't get it you've little punk
[ __ ] you don't know what it's like
listen if people talk about lizard
people then find out they're right me
and Ray were saying this is why people
go so [ __ ] nuts me and rain you have
[ __ ] everything we knew I [ __ ] all
government was but then most people just
found out about it with kid [ __ ] so
that's that's how their minds melted
because if you know how bad if you knew
about Kennedy and about all of these
coos that we did if you knew about these
democratically if you knew about how
fake everything was and the murder an
assassination of blackmail you knew this
[ __ ] the CIA was into if you paid
attention if you'd read any of those
books if you knew our you know our
appetite
for skullduggery and the things that we
had done other people children if you
knew about MKULTRA if you knew about
that shed then once you got to the
pedophile cults in epstein you were kind
of like uh yeah this is a heinous but
logical conclusion to the infrastructure
the groundwork that we already laid in
our mind but if you just arrived at that
your mind melts and that's what you're
seeing his people's minds melt she like
oh [ __ ] wait what
it's crazy if your entrance point into
how [ __ ] up everything is is yours
private islands were politicians and
[ __ ] kids
your mind will melt and I'm not saying
it's not shocking if you if you knew
other things but it's less shocking if
you knew what these people are capable
of if you just know what they're capable
of you're not lying you're like yeah
this is what we had thought it could be
and it is that but that's what people's
minds are mouthing and they're they
don't know what to do so I think that's
where the Qi on stuff comes in it's like
they're just looking to believe things
you know they're looking to they're like
well I hope to god that everything's you
know but now it'll be okay right
they're like but now because that's what
all these things are like but now it's
good because now we're in the distal
secret war Netanya like well I don't
know hopefully you're right hopefully
there is a sequel I don't you know what
am i telling you I would love if there
was a secret war and good people won
great you know but I just you know it's
like thinking that Donald Trump is
leading that war to me is I almost have
to believe that one of these Realtors on
Bravo is doing it because there's it's
the same type of person they I would
almost have to believe that you know
yeah one of the guys from million dollar
listing is uh fighting a secret war to
free all the kids that are being [ __ ]
really good you would say good you'd go
bad the guy from million dollar listing
did showed the house to
big house with the rooftop pool he's
doing the secret war oh well I'm I'm
happy about that I'm not against that
I'm for that if it's happening I'm for
it
I you know I have no investment in it
not happening bad you know that's what
Ari Shaffir has to do to get in
everyone's good graces he's got to
figure out who killed Epstein Ari's got
to solve the Jeffrey Epstein murder and
then come back with a fire tweet naming
the perpetrator John McAfee did it
recently he's like it was dark Taglioni
it was just prison guard and we're
piecing the other things together he's
like if you know how it happened I'll
buy you dinner it's like okay
Prince Andrew not cooperating that's a
shock it's a shock to shock they're
still trying like they're still there's
still elements I'm sure the FBI that
have some good people in them and
they're still like trying to there's you
know we wish everyone luck you just Lane
Maxwell in a few years will be somebody
buying a house in one of these Bravo
real-estate shows you know the below is
one thing I know about your slide she
loves the stunning a sky she's lying as
a socialite she's made of money hanging
out people in a lost aisle it's all
gonna show her house in the bird streets
the birds feature like the hot Hollywood
Hills you people don't know the truth
Dale estates a lot of this stuff is
gated when I was a kid I grew up we used
to drive through wealthy areas and smoke
pot in the car and that's how you know
why privilege it's annoying to hear but
it is true because I literally used to
get high and look at all my friends ago
I want to see the mansions and we would
just drive around mansions just stoned
and on other things and then we just get
out of the car sometimes like creep
creep up the lawn of these old mansions
I'd be smoking a cigarette I'm like look
at this
but hey it's gorgeous weed I was driving
through Sands Point Long Island one day
I was smoking pot my buddy Tom who's now
works for the government
he's like a US Marshal and we were
driving and we had the windows down
we're smoking pot driving through all
these mansions and I was just screaming
about my luck
these people are so much better than us
there's so much better than us and I
wasn't kidding I was awake and aware and
and I got and that was fun you can't do
that in California cuz of the goddamn
gates these [ __ ] scaredy cats they
always need to be behind the gates but
in Long Island a lot of those areas
weren't Gators you could drive around
you know all coked out look at Christmas
lights there was something nice to be
coked out and look at Christmas lights
it's much nicer when you're stoned
obviously it's nicer it's nicer when
you're stoned you have a little hot
chocolate from Dunkin Donuts and you can
go to look at the lights so fun